welcome everyone
I'm Karen Albright and today I'll be
speaking to you about secondary stroke
prevention from the bench to the bedside
I'm a vascular neurologist and an
epidemiologist by training and so our
objectives today are to describe the
role that platelet function phenotype
cyp2c19 genotype and ABC B one genotype
may play an antiplatelet selection in
the future as you know in the past we
had some medicines that caused a lot of
side effects currently our antiplatelet
medications for secondary stroke
prevention are a little better
we have various medications such as
aspirin agronomics and clopidogrel and
as you can see from the chart here each
of these medications has a different
class and level of evidence with aspirin
having the highest class and level
followed by agra knocks in clipit ago
being the third in secondary stroke
prevention we also have dual
antiplatelet therapy which is aspirin
and plavix and that usually is in three
different protocols
sampras chance and point for the
purposes of this talk we won't get into
the details of that but I just want you
to know that those exist so the future
all joking aside is really moving from
trial and error medicine to genotype
based treatment so historically
providers have given patients drug a try
this drug let me know how it goes if the
patient gets side effects they trigger
them B if the problem come up with or
isn't handled we consider it ineffective
and go to drug C but in the future and
her house currently we may move to
genotype based treatment where you know
patients genotype and you select the
drug or dosage based on that
for example in some electronic medical
records if you were to try to order in
this case for a con us all you would
learn the metabolizer status and get
instructions to use a reduced dose you
could either check below for the age and
phenotype adjust the deserve dose which
they've offered here or if you want to
continue with the different dose you
could override it so I'm going to tell
you a few stories about patients that
I've taken care of and their experiences
and mine with precision medicine so the
first is mrs. are mrs. R is a 76 year
old Caucasian woman who came to the
hospital complaining that her right foot
was dragging her history was significant
40 is an ischemic stroke as she reported
she had had four of these she also had
high blood pressure and high cholesterol
she was on secondary stroke prevention
medications and she was thinking
clopidogrel or plavix for her
antiplatelet agent she was taking a
high-dose statin and had been on the
appropriate blood pressure medications
when she needed them so looking at
provider and patient behavior the first
question we asked is were secondary
stroke prevention medications prescribed
for her and yes they were as we just
covered the second question is was she
adherent to these medications and yes
according to her pharmacy records she
was so how can the correct prescribing
of secondary stroke prevention
medications and adherence to those
medications result in a recurrent stroke
so let's talk a little bit about
ischemic stroke so what is an ischemic
stroke ischemic strokes occur generally
when blood clots block an artery and
prevent blood flow to an area of the
brain and as you can see here in blue
this is an area of brain that did not
receive proper blood flow oxygen etc
because of
why so how did one class form well one
thing important in blood clots are
platelets and the platelets are cell
fragments they have no nucleus and as
you can see in the lower picture here
they are lens shaped when they are not
activated but when they become activated
they get dendritic extensions and that's
what you see here platelets contain
granules that release clotting mediators
once activated and they can clump
together to form a platelet plug which
is our primary mechanism blood clotting
or hemostasis so how do these
antiplatelet agents that we prescribe to
stroke patients work how do they prevent
recurrent stroke and you can see in the
picture here each of these green lines
is one pathway that can lead to platelet
aggregation so our first medicine in
medicine at the highest level in class
of evidence is aspirin and what it does
is irreversibly inhibits cox-1 and by
doing that it blocks the formation of
thromboxane a2 our second medicine is
Agra Knox and Agra Knox is a combination
of diaper animal and aspirin and this
works by inhibiting phosphodiesterase
type 5 enzyme and that's through the
cyclic a and P pathway our third
medication and fourth medication our
loop integral and hikinggirl are and
these medications bind to the receptors
for a DP on platelets surface these
drugs are closely related but
clopidogrel is irreversible whereas take
a girl or is reversible so how can we
know if mrs. RS clip integral is
actually inhibiting her platelet
aggregation one option is something
called light transmission agronomy tree
this assesses in vitro platelet to
Playland
Club formation and we can investigate
different
pathways by using different agonist such
as collagen arachidonic acid and ADP LTA
not uses plasma platelet-rich plasma as
you see in the picture on the left and
you can see the cells they're not
clunked whereas on the right after
you've added an aggregating agent they
are clumped and the difference in the
left and the right is the amount of
light that passes through and we can
actually quantify that LTA is very labor
and time intensive now we have newer
tests one example is verify now which is
up kornek air test this comes with two
different cartridges the aspirin
cartridge and the p2y one two cartridges
which works for both five cents I can
girl or and this correlates well with
the LTA but does not require so much
manpower and time how it works is you
have a cartridge containing by brynan
fibrinogen coated beads and then the
agonist you want to add for example adp
if you're testing products as you can
see there on the left there's a tube
this is verify now that contains whole
blood that is literally put into the
Machine then the platelets clump on the
fibrinogen coated beads so when they
clump it increases the amount of light
that gets transmitted through the sample
so inhibited platelets do not clump on
the beads and this decreases the amount
of light so the one that's circled now
is where it's not clumping and you have
less light passing through and the one
on the right they do close and you can
see more light passes through so the p2
y12 cartridge measures p2 why want to
reaction units and while this bedside
test is very useful it can be confounded
by other medications such as plate Allah
and to b3 a and have
here's an example in our plot here you
can see on the x-axis we have receptor
reactivity which in this case is Pru and
on the y-axis we have event risk our
therapeutic window for PR u is between
85 and 208 anything in red is below 85
which is our leading risk and anything
on the right and gray above 208 is our
schema or clock risk so our goal is to
be somewhere between 85 and 208 verify
now also has an aspirin cartridge and
that measures a are you aspirin reaction
units and you can see that this can be
confounded by also to be three
inhibitors but other drugs as well such
as dye peretta model which is found in
Agra Knox clopidogrel and NSAIDs here's
a similar graph for a our new and you
can see that the values changed the red
portion describes less than 350 and the
gray portion
greater than 549 so here
the therapeutic window for aspirin is
350 to 549 before you perform one of
these tests you need to ensure that the
patient has adherence to the drug and we
need about seven days to know that this
can be accomplished through pill count
or pharmacy records where you calculate
the proportion days covered another
option is the a question more risky
questionnaire for medication adherence
so returning to our patient misses are
when we looked at her platelet function
studies we found this is the report the
aggregation and ATP release to the other
agonist thrombin collagen and ATP were
within normal limits now this is a woman
who was taking clopidogrel therefore
mrs. R was a clip integral hypo
responder and sometimes you'll see in
the literature these folks described as
non
responders or even as having high on
treatment platelet reactivity or
over-reactive platelets so what would
make someone who was adherent to
complete a girl a non responder well one
thing is that the Pitta grill itself is
a prodrug pro drugs must be activated in
order to have the desired
pharmacological effects so clopidogrel
itself will not have the effect you want
in your body it must be converted to its
active form so to convert a pro drug to
its active metabolite it must be
absorbed in the intestine and it must
undergo bio activation in the liver and
specifically we know that clopidogrel
under those to oxidative steps you can
see here on the left that cyp2c19 does
45% of the first oxidative stab and 21%
of the second step so sip to see 19 is
very involved in the activation of loop
integral so is it possible that mrs. arm
was unable to activate the fit a girl to
look into this we have to think about
the citizen to see 19 protein this is
the major enzyme as we just saw involved
in the generation of the active
metabolite of clopidogrel and it's
encoded by a gene of the same name this
chain is located on the long arm of
chromosome 10 and what we're talking
about here when we talk about a gene
that's affecting the way a drug is
metabolized or the side-effects that it
might cause we're talking about
pharmacogenomics this is the study of
all genes involved in a response to a
drug in pharmacogenomics is often used
for the study of the interface of
genomics genetics and drugs used in
clinical therapeutics so for mrs. our
could it be that her response to
clopidogrel is related to her since we
see 19 genotype
this is a reminder for those of you who
do not remember alleles but alleles are
just gene variants and in in this
picture here you get a large and a small
way from your father a large and a small
me from your mother and the combination
of those makes up your genotype
different alleles can lead to different
observable characteristics which we
refer to as phenotypes so here the city
to see 19 alleles or genotype predicts
metabolizer
phenotype and we have some common
alleles there are other alleles
I believe 35 or more but we're just
going to focus on the most common ones
here star one which is your wild-type
allele is normal function and start to
through start a or loss of functional
rules on the other end of the spectrum
the star 17 which is a gain of
functionally now when you bring those
alleles together and you create a dip
low type and from that dip low type we
can predict your phenotype and your
enzyme activity so for example if you
have two wild-type alleles we predict
you will be an extensive metabolizers
with normal activating if you have one
gained a function allele or two we
predict that you will be an ultra-rapid
metabolizer with increased or normal
enzyme activity if you have two loss of
function alleles we predict you will be
a poor metabolizer and have low or
deficient enzyme activity and if you
have one wild-type and one loss of
function or one loss of function and one
gain of function we predict you will be
an intermediate metabolizers
with intermediate enzyme activity so how
common are these metabolizer phenotypes
by ancestry so the ones who are
concerned about are the intermediate
metabolizers and the poor metabolizers
so for those who are asian-americans
it's over 50% for african-americans it's
over 30
özkan Azam jewish-americans over 27%
Caucasian Americans nearly 25% and
Hispanic Americans over 23% so these
individuals who are clopidogrel hypo
responders require a different
antiplatelet agent the usual dose of
plavix 75 milligrams daily is not going
to have the same effect in intermediate
in poor metabolizers as it does in
normal metabolism so when we checked
missus our city to see 19 genotype we
found that she was a star to star 70 and
you can go to the secret page and
actually enter that data so here we've
entered star to star 17 and it tells us
the implications are reduced platelet
inhibition increased residual platelet
aggregation and increased risk for
adverse cardiovascular events it also
makes recommendations and tells us that
an alternate antiplatelet therapy would
be recommended if not a contraindicated
so are these alleles clinically relevant
I mean is this simply about
pharmacokinetics or does this affect an
individual so I'll provide for you a
couple examples from the literature and
one is acute coronary syndrome here set
to see 19 loss of function allele
carriers were found to be an increased
risk of major cardiovascular events and
stent thrombosis and in addition a gene
dose relationship was observed meaning
that having one of these alleles puts
you an increased risk but having two of
these alleles which would even higher
risk so what would a cardiologist do for
Miss Bazaar if she had acute coronary
syndrome was about to undergo PC I
needed a stent placed they would follow
her genotype
see that she is the third column on the
right intermediate metabolizers star to
star 17 and they would consider an
alternate antiplatelet agent well can we
use as vascular neurologists can we use
these newer agents so one of the agents
they recommend is press a girl this is
also a prodrug and also require sip to
see 19 to be activated 69 to see 19 does
not play such a major role in the
metabolism of Prosecco as it does with
clopidogrel but it's important
nonetheless the issue here is that the
FDA has a warning against using
procedural in patients with a history of
TI a stroke or intracranial bleeding so
what about tech a girl or tyke a girl or
that this drug sip to see 19 was not
required for drug metabolism and I'll
show you one of our stroke studies this
was called the Socrates trial over
13,000 TIAA or non severe ischemic
stroke patients were enrolled in this
trial and loaded with either chuck hagel
or aspirin followed by a daily dose and
what we saw here is take a girl or
provided a relative risk reduction of
stroke and the composite outcome of
stroke and mine death however the
confidence intervals included one
leading risks were similar in both
groups so what should a vascular
neurologists do it says we should
consider an alternative antiplatelet
agent and someone with starching star 17
but press a girl has a warning in anyone
who's not a history of stroke and take a
girl or did not through the study I
shown you show superiority over aspirin
well maybe we should take a step back
and just ask does sit to see 19 genius I
really matter in recurrent stroke the
bench and to answer this question we
have a systematic review and
meta-analysis here they compare
intermediate metabolizers or and Foreman
catalyzers as the exposure event in
interest excuse me
to everyone else and the outcome was
recurrent stroke weather ischemic or
hemorrhagic 15 studies went into this
too were post hoc of randomized
controlled trials and 13 were cohort
studies
unfortunately eight of these studies did
not collect CTC 19 star 17 there were
over 4,700 patients in the study most of
these studies were from East Asia only
three studies included European ancestry
and there were fewer than 100 and
african-americans so if we look here you
can see highlighted in red is higher
risk of stroke these are risk ratios
this first one we're looking at
individuals who have one loss of
function allele or carriers and we're
comparing them to everyone else and a
risk ratio of 1 means no difference so
here we see those with one loss of
function allele have one point seven
nine times the risk as those who don't
have a loss of function allele well what
if you have two loss of function will or
in other words are a poor metabolizer so
if that is the case you will see that
the risk of recurrent stroke is two and
a half times value of those who have no
loss emotionally so I think we can
conclude that since you see 19 loss of
function allele is associated with
recurrent stroke based on the data we
have available and that there's a
biologic gradient so what we know today
I mean we know that these are things
associated with Mambo's us whether it's
MI or stroke sit Tuesday nineteen loss
of function alleles as well as hypo
response to antiplatelet agents also
known as high in treatment platelet
reactivity
so both genotype and phenotype
be measured in a valid reproducible
manner does this fit with our clinical
observations do clinical observations
fit with polish studies so I'm going to
show you two patients first patient is
mr. w he is an avid instructor this is a
56 year old Asian American man who came
to my clinic complaining of recurrent
stroke symptoms he has a history of a
right pontine infarct high blood
pressure high cholesterol diabetes and
obstructive sleep apnea he had been
placed on dual antiplatelet therapy in
the past for severe right vertebral
artery stenosis after 90 days his
aspirin was stopped and he was continued
only on clopidogrel and high-dose statin
he complained to me that he had been in
the emergency room seven times in the
last four years and when we calculated
his adherence it was greater than 80% so
again we're seeing the correct
medications were prescribed to prevent
recurrent stroke the patient is adherent
in these medicines and yet he's
complaining of recurrent cia's so we
genotypes mr. W and he is a star one
star too so for city to see 19 this
implies reduced platelet inhibition
increased residual Butlin aggregation
and of course increased risk for adverse
cardiovascular events so what did we do
we shared this information with him and
replaced his Kolkata girl with two baby
aspirin she's quite happy about this
because his copay for climax was $75 a
lot and he has had no stroke symptoms
since this change was made which is
almost two years so I flipped this
picture version our second patient is
mrs. R and she's mrs. our number two
since we opened with her mrs. R this is
a 66 year old Caucasian woman who was
admitted to the hospital for worsening
right leg
miss her history is significant for a
prior stroller which cost her to have
some remaining witness on the right side
hypertension and coronary artery disease
she had been placed on Capitol Hill
because of her prior stroke but was not
able to tolerate a stab wound because of
muscle pain her MRI showed that she had
bilateral a CA inference
despite being adherent to Kalitta girl
in fact she was 90 percent here if
you're wondering why how she had my
little ACA in first it turns out that
both of our ACS came from her left
internal carotid artery
so she was prescribed the correct
medications she was adherent to those
medicines and yet she had a recurrent
stroke so the first thing we did for
mrs. our number two is looked at her
platelet function testing once integral
in her PR you came back to them being as
I said we had checked adherence on her
we made sure she had no medications
which would cause drugs from gene
interactions and yet she looks like
she's at risk for clotting
we replaced her clopidogrel in Psych a
girl or and then rechecked her PR you
this time it was 42 putting her at
potential risk for bleeding now because
her stroke came from her carotid we had
to work with our interventionist because
he wanted to place a spent and would not
place a stent unless she was in
tournament range
she never perfectly got to target range
she was too high and clip integral and
perhaps too low on takigawa nonetheless
she continues on tyke a girl or with no
stroke symptoms and no bleeding problems
since that we Gina tighter and we're
very surprised to find that she was a
star 1 star 17 and had to ask why was
her Pru elevated
thattagirl when she did not have a cent
to c-19 loss-of-function wheel so we had
to return to to the bench to think again
about how fluid aromas absorbed so
there's a blank of protein transporter
that actually can limit competi grow
intestinal absorption if you don't
absorb it you can't bio activate it so
we know that certain ABC v1 variants are
associated with decreased coconut oil
absorption lower levels of active
metabolite an increased risk of sombody
events how common is that well in one
randomized control trial 26 more than
26% participants had a variant that was
associated with decreased clip integral
absorption so this taught us a lesson
that genotype matters right now we're
focused on like a proteins value affect
absorption on enzymes that affects bio
activation and there are probably many
others so what is the future some would
argue that the future is now
for example many patients come to clinic
with the pharmacogenomic report here's
an example this is one where it shows
you by category if you were interested
in anticoagulants and your patient
brought this report it says this patient
also has a peak or c1 period that could
further alter dosing considerations of
warfarin many of these reports also show
you drawn by drug and here on the right
you can see each genotype how this may
affect and how you shouldn't change
dosing and on the far right stars show
you the level of evidence so currently
we have the capability of evaluating an
individual and see if they are
appropriately responding to enhance a
platelet agent do they have high on
treatment platelet reactivity
and we can use genetic information to
predict who is likely to not respond
appropriately to particular medications
and some of that I showed you the
example of the reporter patients bring
to clinic so putting this all together
if we combine our current testing
methods with an evidence-based algorithm
we could select the best medication for
each individual patient then possibly
reduce recurrent vascular events and
even adverse drug events and we are
currently working on a pilot study
passport or the personalized
antiplatelet secondary strong prevention
trial this is an exploratory trial where
we are evaluating the safety and
feasibility of an early initiated
phenotype and genotype driven precision
medicine approach to antiplatelet
therapy in ischemic stroke survivors so
this is the future this is the present I
would be happy to take any questions I
provided my email at the beginning of
this talk so if you have a question just
feel to feel free to email me and I'd be
happy to answer it thank you for your
attention